prix de l'interprétation masculine va à
antonio banderas dollars
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous n'avez pas idée de combien
j'aimerais pouvoir parler français mais
je ne peux pas en même temps je ressens
le besoin de parler espagnol parce qu'il
s'agit d'un film espagnol et que c'est
mon pays que je représente
je représente le cinéma espagnol donc je
vais essayer de faire une sorte de
paille avec les deux langues anglais
espagnol
lorsque je monte les marches j'ai vu il
m'a dit combien de temps cet aveu prix
pour venir alors je pense qu'il peut
demander avec le recul si vous devenez
d'espagne ou de l'ombre
ma première réponse a été 40 ans 40 ans
est-ce que
et son plein c'est un prix pour lequel
je suis très reconnaissant en mon nom en
tant qu'acteur et les noms mais aussi
pour mon personnage ya encore peu
ceux-là mêmes ces gamins si le
personnage s'appelle salvador maillot il
nous les fait de mystère pour personne
que salvador maillot c'est pedro
almodovar
[Applaudissements]
j'ai rencontré pedro almodovar il ya 40
ans on a fait huit films ensemble
je le respecte je les admire je laime
c'est mon mentor
il m'a tellement tellement donné tout au
long de ma vie
on vire que cette récompense évidemment
doit lui être dédié
parce que on a parcouru la vie ma vie
professionnelle tout le monde pense
qu'on vit sur un tapis rouge mais c'est
pas vrai que je souffre beaucoup c'est
beaucoup de sacrifices et c'est beaucoup
de douleur beaucoup de douleur derrière
le métier d'acteur ou d'artistes en
général mais il ya également des soirs
des soirs de gloire et ce soir c'est mon
soir de moi je souhaite le célébrer le
fêter dix ans quelque chose qui vient du
coeur
tout comme le meilleur est encore à
venir
merci infiniment c'est en effet le
premier preuve pour des majeurs de celui
qu'elle ait trouvé le premier rôle
important de sa carrière en courant
labyrinthe des passions d'almodovar et
il incarne à l'écran le double
d'almodovar un cinéaste en pleine crise
existentielle à cri un hommage rendu
fait remonter à la surface se soudent de
son passé d'enfant d'homme et d'artiste
il était déjà venu en compétition des
fronts de shrek et la piel que habito
d'almodovar actuellement en salle tout
le règle war a réussi un excellent
démarrage avec déjà plus de 230 mille
entrées
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]